in the previous part of the session we
had seen different ways in which we
could find the number of ways in which
we could select three objects out of
five different objects in this part we
will look at arrangement of three
objects out of five distinct ones as we
plan to arrange three objects out of
five we can make three slots for them
the first slot can be filled with any
one of the five objects it means there
are five ways in which we can pick the
first object after one object is picked
up just four remain for the second one
and three remain to be chosen from for
the third one as the order matters
each arrangement will be different so we
don't divide this by three factorial
like we did before so these many ways in
which we can arrange three objects out
of five distinct ones another way to
look at it is by numbering the objects
from one to five in the previous case
three was selected and as their order
did not matter we put each of them in
the S category but here the three
objects have to be arranged so we need
to put the 3 selected objects in
different categories the three different
categories could be labeled a B and C as
the order matters ABC will be different
from a C B or B a C and what about the
two objects that are not selected should
each of them be put in different
categories no they should be put in the
same category if these two are not
selected we can say that 4 & 5 are not
selected or 5 & 4 are not selected it
doesn't matter they mean the same both
are not selected so we can put them in
the NS category now that we have made
the categories we can calculate the
number of ways in which this can be done
five distinct objects can be arranged in
five factorial ways and as two out of
these five are in the same category we
divide this by two factorial this will
also give us the same answer 60 ways and
also have to formula to find the number
of ways in which we can arrange three
out of five we can use the NPR formula
we use permutation as we have to arrange
the objects arrange our objects from n
distinct objects it equals n factorial
over n minus R factorial here as we have
to arrange three out of five it will be
five P three based on the formula it
will be five factorial divided by five
minus three factorial this will also
give us the same answer so by now either
using logic or using the formulae you
should know the different ways in which
we can approach any problem based on
permutations and combinations
you